now the media obviously doesn't like
Crowder Crowder is competition to CNN
the same way Joe Rogan is competition to
CNN or I am or D Dan banino Etc so if if
he is to expose anything good not good
in in and of itself but if he is to
expose anything that is true well then
they have to go after Crowder uh so
here's a tweet from Crowder uh he said
we called it this morning expect hit
pieces from leftwing media saying we
released the Nashville Manifesto for
clicks and clout I assure you Crowder
doesn't need clicks and clout and here
he has an email from a New York Times
quote unquote journalist Emily Cochran
uh and she says hi there my name is
Emily Cochran and I'm a reporter with
the New York Times I'm working on a
story on Mr Crowder's publication of the
Covenant writings and just left a press
conference where one parent Brent
Leatherwood was critical of the decision
to publish those photos he described it
as chasing clicks at one point and said
that the proceeds from the video should
go to the families of the six victims
Andor school I watched the video earlier
this morning and we'll incorporate some
of that but wanted to make sure Mr
Crowder didn't have any additional
comment or response to the push back
thank you Emily okay so first off
relative to how these Jour quote unquote
journalists operate Emily's not terrible
right there right she's she's addressing
a specific thing she's saying I watched
your video and I want to give you a
chance to comment generally these people
they tell you oh you've got five minutes
to respond to me my hit the HIIT piece
is about to come out or they don't
comment you know they don't ask you to
comment at all um I would say look I
have
incredible I don't know how to describe
it any other way I have incredible
empathy and Sympathy for the father of
one of these victims uh I I think that
you know that and he doesn't want this
out he doesn't want it rehashed but
again I think we kind of do need to know
some of the motivations here
notwithstanding what I just said earlier
about the way they can manipulate that
by writing crazy things and everything
else um we also know that if if this
wasn't a trans person right if this had
been a white supremacist let's say or
just a white guy just a Christian white
guy there's no way this this Manifesto
would have been hidden they would have
got oh my God he watched Tucker Carlson
and Steven Crowder he voted for Donald
Trump and Joe Biden would have been
giving speeches and they would have been
going after the guns and all of that
stuff